nate of aldi four and two with the 363
era yeah looking for win number five
coming off a six inning one run piece in
texas nice outing a lot of weapons to
get out this detroit lineup one out for
jonathan scope it looks like the lapra
it's gonna be a swing and a miss for
strike three as scope goes down oh
please gas slider slider see you later
and there is the second out now
remember candelario who with a three run
homer in the tenth inning last night and
had three hits he's up to 284 he's been
their best hitter one two looked like he
pulled him yes he did that's a swing and
a miss strike three
of aldi was already headed off the hill
he was certain of it spencer turnbull
today
threw a very good first game for the
tigers uh mixed since then
swings and misses have been going down
however he's been working on that slider
don't want to say this but this is just
because i'm going with the first lock
he's 1-16 in day games tigers will play
the infield in in the first inning with
jd up but with the two run homer last
night his 10th he's leading the league
in that and rbi is with 29 alex cora
coming out of the dugout looks like [ __ ]
he was out there kind of moving around
strange and cordero's ready to come into
this game i don't know what [ __ ] did on
that double but watching him lead off
second base he's coming out of the game
yeah he started walking towards court
you knew he was done
so cordero the runner and that's gonna
be floated in a left center field down
for a base set red sox on the board
cordero in the score
that's 30 runs batted in for jd martinez
who just consistently gets it done yeah
try to get in on him he just couldn't he
fought that ball off didn't smoke it
but on a line to center field he's in
one of those grooves right now where you
can't get the ball in on him because his
hand discipline is so good he's coming
in tight to his body he's able to clean
those pitches out put him on a line
somewhere and two away and here's
francie cordero to come in for an
injured [ __ ] hernandez he rips that one
he's all over it that's going to chase
and run fairball down the line
and to score flowecky
scampering into second francie cordero
and the red sox lead a two to nothing
franchi franchi franti with a double
here rbi he come out of his shoes on a
piece of cheese didn't he and franchi
cordero with a bullet hands it over 25
with a rocket down the right field line
hit on the dirt and get under the
padding not far from the pesky pole and
sort of stop jones moves up to third
there's one away akil badu has a chance
for an rbi
right back up the middle it bounces off
vivaldi
jones is going to score they get padou
at first base but the tigers are on the
board i think that ball went off of
vivaldi and maybe deflected two boguards
as a good play by bogarts to charge
field and fire to get a speedy runner
the tigers down 2-1 the red sox have
them at first and second here's devers
with two on and none out there's a line
drive in the left field that's what they
said jd comes to third he's going to be
waved home by carlos fey place jones
will throw to second it's an rbi hit for
devers and it's three to one red sides
what's the temperature on that ground
ball basin that ball was scalded they're
all scalded everything he hits is called
a
little
something hot change up that's taking
back over the place
there's nobody there to
get a chance to even field that ball
balls called it i mean everything he
hits is hard on the corners here for
plawecki who doubled he breaks his back
but it dies a hero a single in the left
and another run is in bogart scores good
day for flowecky two for two and it's
four to one big knock right there a
little slaughtered down in the way the
barrel ended up pretty much between the
mound and the third base line
went about halfway down the line before
we get rid of the handle threw it
towards the red sox dugout first two men
aboard here for the tigers in the fourth
got to do some damage in this inning
sends one to right center that ball is
going to bounce all the way into the
wall
one run is home
nice job by wilson ramos that rbi double
three straight hits for the tigers to
start the fourth and it's four to two
that was a
spinner right down the heart of the
plate did not try to pull the ball got
to barrel the bat out in front it jumped
off his bat
and went a long way
but to see the tigers bounce back with
free straight hits off the stuff that
vivaldi has this afternoon that's really
good approach to hitting tigers have
made it 4-2 and a basic could tie the
game first pitch here a line drive and a
base hit into left field
again took the 98 and drove it away one
run in ramos being waved around third he
will score line drive two run single for
harold castro tigers have tied it at
four in the fourth
just incredible what they've just done
this guy looked to me like he has this a
game but that bat speed
of harold castro is something that he's
a slap hitter
and able to move the ball around that's
98 a little above almost a little below
the belt bogey has singled and been hit
by a pitch scored a run he bats here
with two down and jd at second four to
four is the score and through his man a
little pop in the center coming on jones
he can't get to it here comes jd in the
score
he touches home down to second is xander
bogarts
red sox take the lead so a little
revenge there kind of flipped the bat at
it and picks up the hit there's a second
and third one out nikko goodrum turns
around bets righty against the lefty
ball the dirty goes right by the catcher
plowacki and the tigers have tied it up
into score comes jonathan scope on a
wild pitch candelario to third five five
game in the fifth
swinging a shot knocked down on the
right side by dolbeck he'll underhand to
the pitcher taylor but he had no chance
to get it and the tigers take a six-five
lead here in the fifth i know it's hard
to believe but the blue birds are out in
fenway
candelario two for three today five for
eleven with two walks
in the series
swinging a line drive base hit into
right field pass gonzales rounding third
and heading home is grossman the throw
goes to third not in time chamber
candelario delivers he went down and got
the change up rip the single then to
right seven five tigers in the sixth yes
sir baby you feel really good what a
good approach to hitting that time two
men aboard and now here come the big
boys to face farmer jd to start him
swinging a line drive into left field
that's a base hit cordero will come home
and score might have broken his back
it does not matter jd martinez has his
31st rbi base is loaded for raffi with
nobody out red sox trailing by a run
up the middle it squeaks through for a
base hit for dugo is in here comes
martinez to score rafael devers drives
in his second and third runs on the day
and the red sox are back in front 8-7
red sox will draw the infield in tight
for victor reyes three hits in game one
but hitless yesterday and today ground
ball softly to short fielded by bogarts
he'll throw to first to get reyes tigers
tie the game
they backed up the middle of the infield
just enough for victor reyes to get a
run home we've got an 8-8 game at fenway
park grossman's over at third ramos at
the plate on the ground base hit it's
through the left side and the tigers are
back in front 9-8
wilson ramos delivers with two outs well
how about that tigers have scored in six
straight innings
lags 3-2 runners will be off to the
races here with two down there they go
and there's a shot that's a fair ball
here comes debra's in the score arroyo
will stop at third and the red sox have
tied it
so this wild one gets a little wilder
vasquez coming off the bench and
delivers the key hint well red sox have
just tied it nine nine and they have to
go ahead run at third base
and he puts it in play
[Applause]
arroyo scores 10-9 boston on what should
have been the third out of the inning
cordero down to second vasquez in third
up the middle pass the bag and the
center that's going to bring in two runs
and it's 12-9 red sox
hit by verdugo he continues to come
through against lefties
one-two pitch coming
scope swings and pops it up this should
do it christian vasquez throws a mask
away calling in front of home plate fair
ground makes the catch and the red sox
win it
the red sox take the rubber game of the
series